- Maybe it's been a
while since you felt like
you've had your mojo.
Maybe you remember times in the past,
maybe several years ago where
you actually felt incredible,
a lot more incredible than you do now.
I feel like all of us, at
some point in our lives
have had little checkpoints
where we remember feeling incredible.
Either we were in a flow state
where we were inhibited
by our social anxiety,
or maybe times where
you just felt energetic,
enthusiastic about life,
and motivated to actually
take constructive action.
In my life, I feel like I
have finally entered a period
where I feel good.
Most days I feel quite good,
and that's sort of foreign to me.
You know, I'm very prone
to negative emotion,
I get into my head a lot,
and depression runs deep in my family.
So I pay special attention
to the actions that I do
throughout the day,
and how that affects my mental health.
And recently, I've
started doing a few things
that have really helped me feel better,
and I live my life with more energy,
more enthusiasm towards
my work, my personal life,
and overall, it just feels
better to feel this way.
So hopefully through this video,
if you guys are going through a rough time
and you want to enter
into a period of your life
where you just feel better on average,
you're more enthusiastic
to wake up in the morning,
and you wanna feel like
you have your mojo back,
then hopefully some of the things
that I've started doing
can help you as well.
Feel free to experiment,
take it or leave it,
but this is what I've been doing
to make me feel really good.
So number one is very simple.
Every single morning, I've been waking up
at the same time every single day,
and immediately I walk outside
and I smell the fresh air.
And bonus points if the sun is shining
and you see a little bird flying by
and let the hot sun beat
down on your pale face.
I'm talking about me of course.
I have no melanin in my skin whatsoever.
And if I wanna take this one step further,
I'll actually go for a walk.
Before I have my coffee,
I'll put on my running shoes
and I'll go for a walk around the block.
And while this practice
may sound overly simple,
it's kind of a game changer for me,
because I actually feel like endorphins
are rushing through my body.
My brain is getting flushed
with positive neurochemicals.
It also gives me a little window of time
to not look at my phone and
start thinking of the things
that I can accomplish today.
I can think of the people in my life
that I wanna spend time with,
I can think of the
person that I want to be,
and I can be grateful for a fresh start,
a new opportunity to restore order
and contribute to the world
and make a difference hopefully.
And this might sound super cheesy to you.
I mean, it would for me,
if I didn't start going
on these morning walks.
'Cause when you're coed
up in your house all day
and you immediately jump on the internet,
it's hard to have cheesy,
wholesome thoughts like this.
And when someone says
something like this to you,
you might say, "Oh that
sounds overly Disney,
"being thankful for a fresh start."
But honestly, stepping
outside of your house
and getting off the internet
will do that to you.
You will actually start to
have positive thoughts again.
So first thing in the
morning when you wake up,
don't go on your phone,
don't check Twitter.
Walk outside of your
room, put on some runners,
go walk out your front door.
You don't even need to put on shoes.
Just walk out your front door,
fill your lungs with
that fresh, clean air.
Look up at the sun, but not
too long or you'll go blind,
and just take a few seconds to be thankful
for a fresh start and a new day.
That will set the tone for
the entire rest of the day,
and you will never regret doing that.
And that leads very well
into the next thing that I've been doing,
which is intentionally doing things
and going places that elevate my mood.
So this one sounds really obvious,
but I actually don't think it is,
because so often in our lives,
we will do the same
things every single day.
We'll go to work, we'll come home,
we'll sit on the computer.
We tend to do the things
that we've always done,
and we slowly and slowly and slowly
might become more cynical.
We might start to think
that there's no point.
You know, what's the point
of doing the same thing every single day,
waking up and working for the same boss
and the same job that you don't like?
But every once in a while,
your sister might text you and say,
"Hey, do you wanna go for
a walk on the beach shore?"
And you usually say, no,
'cause your super busy,
but this one time, you're like,
"Okay, sure, let's do it."
I haven't hung out with
my sister in a long time.
So you go for a walk on the beach
and you look around and you say,
holy smokes, the world isn't so bad.
The sounds of the seagulls
chirping in the air.
I don't know if seagulls chirp,
they kind of like squawk.
You know, people are walking their dog.
This attractive couple is
on a very awkward first date
and it's fun to people watch them.
And you're getting moving,
the blood is flowing,
and all of a sudden this new experience
gives you a fresh perspective
and it elevates your mood.
But it's so funny because everyone
can kind of relate to this story,
but then they go back to doing
the same thing that they've always done,
slowly becoming more cynical
until they reach a breaking point
and they do the that kind of thing again.
But why not implement the
things that make you feel good
regularly into your life?
Why not have a weekly schedule
of going for a walk on the
beachfront with your sister?
Why not actually go to
that book group on Friday
filled with smiling faces
and attractive people of your same age?
And this is going to be very
different for everybody.
You know, what makes me feel good
might not necessarily make you feel good.
You know the things that
kind of break up that pattern
and make you kind of
excited to be alive again.
Make an effort to make that thing
a regular part of your life,
because those things
are the types of things
that make life worth living.
So try to really evaluate in your life
what are the things that
make you feel inspired,
invigorated, refreshed, and optimistic?
I don't know what that is for you,
but if there is something
that comes to mind,
maybe it's something that you
haven't done in a long time,
make an effort to make that
a regular thing in your life.
It will give your better thoughts,
your more optimistic
viewpoint some more air time,
and over the course of days
and week and months and years,
you'll find that giving
your more optimistic
tendencies more air time
will really benefit your
mental health in the long run.
Okay, so the third thing
that I've been doing
that has really helped me feel incredible
is that I've started to put
more effort into my appearance.
So this is probably gonna be
the most controversial one on this list.
I feel like a lot of self
improvement advice out there,
including some I've
probably given as well,
has really emphasized the point
that external circumstances
won't necessarily make you happier.
You know, if you buy a new
car, you get a fancy house,
you get a cool dog that,
you know, people compliment you on,
you know, these things won't
make you a better person,
especially if the desire to attain
these material possessions comes
from a place of insecurity.
You know, if you're feeling
really bad about yourself,
like you have really low
self-esteem and low self-worth,
then buying a new shirt and
spending a bunch of money
on a new iPhone probably
isn't gonna help you.
It'll just distract you for a day.
I think everyone knows this,
but I think there also
is something to be said
about dressing in a way
and presenting yourself to the world
in a more dignified way,
in a way that reflects
your inherent dignity
and worth as a person.
So the clothing choices that you have
and the fact that you cut
your hair and trim your nails
isn't necessarily what makes
you have value as a person,
but it sure as hell reflects it.
And as we've talked
about in previous videos,
your subconscious is very perceptive.
It's constantly evaluating other people
and making judgment calls about them,
but it's also doing the same thing to you.
So when you wear clothes that don't fit,
if you wear clothes that are extremely
kind of drab and uninspiring,
you're not showering,
you're not trimming your
beard or cutting your hair,
your subconscious is
picking up on these things.
It is evaluating your appearance
and making a judgment call of
your self-worth based on that.
So there's almost no avoiding it.
It's an automatic mechanism.
And it's almost like a
chicken or the egg thing,
because by getting a fresh haircut,
by buying nice clothes that fit you,
and by showering and
taking care of yourself
and appearing well in the world
and orderly in the world,
your subconscious does look at that
and it will feel better
about your self-worth.
Obviously this isn't a permanent solution,
but it all contributes to
this feeling of dignity.
Man, it really sounds like I'm
just rationalizing the fact
that I got some new drip recently.
I don't know if you need
to do this much thinking
before buying new clothes,
but hopefully you can see
where I'm coming from.
I do really believe that
if you're more proud
of the clothes that you put
on, the haircut that you have,
or the lack of hair,
and just keeping shit
tight against your head,
I do feel like you'll go about the world
in a more confident way.
It's kind of like making
your bed in the morning,
and you can't just restore
order to the whole kingdom
by cleaning the foyer,
but cleaning the foyer
does reflect the fact
that you're an orderly kingdom,
or that you on an orderly
kingdom or whatever.
I don't know.
I'm bad at allegory today.
But I feel great.
Okay, So the fourth thing
is that I've been keeping
a list to restore order.
So in the notes app of my phone,
I keep this list called "Things in Order,"
and I have a giant inventory
of all of the main domains of my life
that I could be restoring order to.
It starts with my physical surroundings.
Is my bedroom clean, is the office clean?
The top floor, the main
floor, the basement?
How about my finances,
where am I at with that?
My habits, how are those?
You know, my social
life, my spiritual life.
I really flesh out each
category of my life
and what criteria I would have
in order for me to consider
that domain relatively orderly.
So this might seem kind of obsessive,
and I feel like there's a
self-improvement philosophy
that is making its way
through the internet
that would be tempted.
A philosophy that would be tempted.
Philosophy, philosophies
don't get tempted.
But if you hold this philosophy,
you might be tempted to
say, that's self-obsessive,
you're setting yourself up for misery,
because that's conditional happiness.
You have a big criteria of things
and achievements that you have to hit
before you can feel
totally satisfied in life.
But I think that's completely BS,
because the world is always
and constantly in a state of decay.
If you leave things alone,
things always get worse
and disintegrate rather
than stay the same.
Some might call it entropy,
some may call it the
destructive nature of time,
but that's just the way the world works.
If you neglect taking care of your teeth,
your teeth will rot
right out of your skull.
If you don't clean your kitchen
regularly and do the dishes,
a stench will start to develop
and you'll attract pests.
No matter how you spin it,
if you're not constantly
maintaining order,
if you don't live your life
in a mode of being that is constructive,
then time will naturally destruct.
But there's a silver
lining to all of this,
it's not so hamster wheely and fatalistic,
and that silver lining is
that it actually feels good
to restore order in your life.
So when you have this
thorough list of things
that you have to restore
order in your life,
to check those boxes
feels good on the inside.
It makes you feel proud of the
existence that you're living.
When you put your head
on your pillow at night,
you can say, "I put my
time to good use today."
And without that direction in life,
without that game plan
of what you're actually
doing in the present moment
and what you're working towards,
then by definition, you're directionless,
which is kind of synonymous
with meaninglessness.
Directionless? Meaningless?
Either way, it's not good.
So one of the most optimistic things
that I've done recently by I far
is to make this thorough list,
and every single day, I try to check a box
or check a fraction of a box,
and just take inventory of
all the things in my life
that I have autonomy over,
all the things that I can contribute to,
and it helps me feel like
I'm the master of my fate.
The ironic thing is I'm
actually kind of tired.
I didn't get a lot of sleep last night.
So if my eyes are puffy and
I look kind of miserable,
it kind of totally goes
against this whole message.
You might be watching this video
and be like, "Joey says he's okay,
"but he doesn't look okay."
But I feel great.
So the final thing on this
list is a no brainer thing,
but it absolutely has to be covered,
because it's probably
the most important thing.
You just heard it a million times before.
Number Five is that I stop being
an absolute dumb dumb with my health.
There's no getting around the fact
that when you start working out,
when you start being active
and you get the blood
pumping and the iron,
when you start juicing?
No, don't juice.
There's absolutely no
getting around the fact
that when you start going for runs,
you start getting exercise,
you feel like a Greek god.
When you drink enough water,
you feel like Poseidon.
The monotonous things in
life don't feel so drab
and absolutely agonizing to get through.
It's because you actually
have the mental energy
to get through them.
So on average, save for
last night obviously,
I've been getting way more sleep,
I've been drinking more water,
I've been hitting my very
specific supplement stack,
which I'll go over right at the end here,
I've been working out, I've
been doing more cardio,
I've been going outside for walks,
and taking care of my health like this
is the cornerstone of my mental health.
You know, your physical
health and your mental health
are so intimately linked
in ways that are beyond our understanding.
So let's talk about my supplement stack.
That's what everyone's
probably dying to know.
I kind of covered it in a previous video,
but I've kind of modified it.
So I am not advocating or
prescribing anything to you,
I'm just telling you what I take.
Always consult your medical
professional of choice,
your favorite one,
on what you should be
putting into your body.
And I'm not a doctor, I'm just a dude.
But this is what I have
every single morning,
and it makes me feel great.
All right, so my current
supplement stack is Vitamin D,
which I have in oil form
with a olive oil carrier,
so it's Vitamin D3 and K2.
I have 500 milligrams of Vitamin C,
which keeps me healthy
during these viral times.
I take five milligrams
of creatine with water,
and that is actually one of
the only proven nootropics
that apparently contributes
to short-term memory,
which is actually really interesting,
'cause usually it's just
used for body building
and going to the gym and for athletes.
But not only does it help
with your physical energy,
but also your mental energy
and short-term memory,
which is crazy.
I also am a big fan of Maca.
I personally find that
it gives me more energy.
Apparently it boosts libido too.
So the final component
of my supplement stack
is actually using a product
which is also the
sponsor of today's video,
but I've been using them for years,
way before they were a
sponsor of this video,
and I actually reached out to them saying,
"Please sponsor my stuff.
"I'm basically a walking
ad for you anyways,
"so I might as well just
further evangelize in my video,
"and then you can just pay me to do that
"instead of me doing it
for free all the time."
A big thank you to Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this video.
There's a very good reason why AG1
by Athletic Greens is my main supplement.
It's because there's basically
no competing with the amount
of nutrients that's in
one scoop of this stuff.
There's 75 vitamins, minerals,
whole foods sourced super foods,
probiotics and adaptogens
in one convenient daily serving.
AG1 supports your energy,
focus, gut health,
digestion, immunity
system, and mental clarity
without the need to take
multiple products or pills.
Athletic Greens uses these whole foods
and these natural sources
and condenses them down
to this single scoop
which you add to water,
you shake it up and you drink it.
And compared to so many
different health drinks
and greens powders that I've tried
throughout my long history of
trying different nootropics
and trying to optimize my health,
this stuff by far tastes the best.
So it's just a very pleasant
way to start my morning
with the confidence
that I'm giving my body
all the tools that it needs nutritionally
to tackle the day with energy.
So if you're interested in joining me
in this very simple
health optimization habit
that I've been partaking
in for over two years now,
then use my link in the description below
and you'll actually get a year's supply
of the Vitamin D and K2 complex
that I have every single morning
as a well as five AG1 travel
packs with your first purchase.
So once again, if you're interested
in taking advantage of
this incredible offer
and getting a year's
supply of Vitamin D3 and K2
plus five AG1 travel packs
with your first purchase,
then click my link in
the description below,
optimize your health, feel
invigorated and powerful,
and as usual, have a great time.
If you like this video,
make sure that you hit Like.
If you hit the Like
button, then it actually,
the algorithm goes, "Oh,
this is a good video.
"I will shove this guy's bald head
"into other people's
homepages, helping them out,"
which also helps me out,
so it's a win-win for everybody involved.
So make sure you actually
click the button,
because I want you to.
If you're lurking here,
consider subscribing
and hitting that, no,
don't hit the Bell icon.
You don't need any more needless
notifications in your life.
Yeah, just consider subscribing.
It just looks good on paper,
and check out the second channel.
There's a lot of fun stuff on there,
some family vlogs of mine
if you wanna get to know me better,
there's some Q&A videos,
and there's gonna be a lot of fun stuff,
potentially even a podcast
popping up on there pretty soon.
And if you're on Instagram anyways,
which you probably shouldn't be,
because it's cancerous and brutal,
but if you don't follow my advice
and you still go on Instagram,
then you might as well
follow our Instagram,
because it's probably slightly
less of a waste of time
than other people's Instagram.
I don't know. That's a bad pitch.
We just need more followers I think.
But if you don't feel like
following it, don't follow it.
Cool, but other than that,
that is all for today.
Thank you so much for watching,
and we'll catch you in the next video.